[Music]
here we go dom one two three
i gave you my heart but the very next
day
you gave it away
and this year
to save me from tears i'll give it to
someone special
oh last christmas i gave you my heart
but the very next day
you gave it away
this year
save me from tears i'll give it to
someone special
oh
for my money
my favorite christmas song
hey merry christmas bill merry christmas
it's christmas or a slade would say it's
it's chris
hey dom was that whammer george michael
that sang that well that was wham
when they were wham but i think we can
all agree at this point that all of wham
was george michael not much of it was
actually can't say that andrew i went to
see wham yeah and the apollo in glasgow
me and mamey
willie
and every other person in the audience
was a woman
well yeah they were absolute dreamboats
those very very beautiful but then uh
pepsi and shirley were the backing
singers you see lovely enough george
michael for my money is one of the great
modern english soul singers he's
incredible and as my friend ryan would
say he shits melodies
he absolutely shits melody he can't help
himself he's threatened some great songs
hasn't it oh incredible my balls keep
going in my eyes well watch it doesn't
go in your mouth actually yeah it's
quite low isn't it do you know when i
first put this hat on the ball
flew forward and hit me in the eye
and it's still painful i'm sorry about
that
now what's your favorite christmas song
careful
i
would see i like john lynn
so this is christmas and what have you
done what a beautiful sentiment because
they were like we're two of the most
famous people in the world evil's going
to be asking us our opinion we're going
to say
you can stop fighting if you want war is
over if you want if you want it just
stop now just put everything down and
say that's it we're done
wouldn't that be nice done that'd be
great yeah i like that song too i have
to say
a lot of christmas songs make me feel
just a little like a tinge of sadness oh
don't worry about that little melancholy
well it's another year over isn't it but
just think dom it's another one just
begun that's true so that would be your
favorite yeah i think so um love last
christmas as well by joe yeah by wham
wham just builds on that chorus this
that he he presents it and then from
that point on
different octaves coming in very simple
song and the video is brilliant
and it looks like a lovely place that
they've gone to it does with pepsi and
shirley right where's pepsi and shirley
and well you know last year he shared
this love but he's gonna try and find
someone special this year yeah it was it
stayed at number two one of the great
christmas number twos of all time and
was kept off the top spot by
wait a minute it was number two on
christmas day on christmas day and kept
off the top spot by an iconic song not
necessarily well actually it is a
christmas the birthday song no no no no
no no no no um i'll tell you a few
people involved in well maybe i
shouldn't give me hints
it was a collaboration between musicians
oh i've got it um it's the uh i don't
actually know what this song's called
but hold on
uh written by major and bob gildoff and
there won't be snow
in africa this christmas time to be fair
there probably hadn't been snow in
africa since the ice age yeah so that's
not something that they're not used to
and this year they're not going to get
it it never snows in africa since you
know the previous ice age
and i've i i love that so it's a great
song and
obviously it lent its way to kind of
live aid one of the greatest gigs ever
and also the american one we are the
ones and made
a ton of money for that charity
i always had a problem with bono's line
which is tonight thank god it's them
instead of you
go on tonight thank god it's them
know i mean
not sure about that be thankful that
they're dying and not you yeah it's not
good
is that what that line means
i don't like that do you remember the
title of the song yet
or the or the
collective because the american was we
are the world right we are the children
we are the ones um but the british one
no i don't know what it's called
band-aid or live aid
do they know it's
christmas time at all a lot of them
don't because they don't celebrate
christmas
christmas yeah so i don't yeah but so
there's a lot of problems with the
lyrics but i mean a lovely sentiment and
uh made a lot of money for charity
our lives nowadays are so chaotic and so
mad capped sometimes i find myself
eating things that i probably shouldn't
be eating just because i've run out of
time i make poor choices now if you're
like me and sometimes you're kind of a
bit of a lazy eater in terms of the
choices that you make you might need
to start working with noom num is
actually very good dom i like it a lot
because they don't say this is bad food
you don't eat that they educate you on
why you make your decisions and then you
make better decisions if i'm watching a
movie i would like an app to say to me
hey listen if you've got an hour and a
half when you're sitting around instead
of making a silly choice you could make
a more healthy choice whilst enjoying
watching a movie at the same time start
building better habits for healthier
long-term results sign up for your trial
at noom.com
onion that's n o o m dot com slash onion
start building better habits for
healthier long term results sign up for
your trial at noom.com
now do you have any particular christmas
traditions that you stick to each year
um
what we're gonna say cleaning your
christmas baubles yeah yeah of course
you've gotta
clean your bubbles before you stick them
on the tree
uh got the tree up dom have you got a
tree yeah lovely um
yeah i did some shopping
i used my drum machine again so that i
could remember the list oh brilliant do
you want to hear the list love to hear
you crazy hold on hold on here get the
thing get your christmas uh
hold on john
how does your little dog feel about a
christmas tree because he can sometimes
be quite nervous around you know what i
don't even know if he knows there is a
tree right but he uh he's been very
tired and very comfy lately i hadn't
seen him for a few months and he jumped
up into my lap do you remember he was
and he stayed there for about stayed
there for an hour it was great it was so
great fell asleep in my lap right here
we go let's hear your christmas list
so i brought my drum machine with me oh
my christmas should i drum for you could
you please i'd love to here we go
a vitamin c
a tree a fairy with a magic key wrapping
paper mashed potatoes oh french
a nice brown set a cheese and ham brew
sheds uh kate's tapes christmas lights
see oh nice
that's how i remember it dom i would
like out of that list the brie i'm
taking that poinsettia home and the tea
i think a poinsettia is very important
for a christmas uh although it's not my
one of my favorite plants no i'm not
really crazy about that either is it big
in the states and maybe not as big in
our countries huge in america everywhere
you go but they always look fake to me
yeah they do are they fake are they all
thick no i think that's real that's a
real one well i've got one now because
it was on my list so i took it home i
feel sorry for plants that are seasonal
because like this is great but then in a
couple months time people like you got a
poinsettia you don't want that it's a
christmas plant does they really i think
so what if you put it in the garden
would it live in in california um yeah
probably partial shade i would say since
it feels a bit
delicate
um i wonder why it became a christmas
plant in the u.s red i would say
which we should go into uh while we're
wearing red i am wearing uh
christmas merch so this is a friendship
onion hoodie
with a little bit of charming snow
which i absolutely adore isn't that
lovely you look great nice green
and i'm wearing uh friendship onion
socks if you're looking for a stocking
filler or you could use it as a stocking
to put stuff in
friendship onion orange fluorescent
socks you wouldn't get much in them no
you wouldn't and we have been guaranteed
from the supplies that they will not
turn your feet orange repeat not turn
your feet orange they're actually very
comfy very comfortable and i do love the
hoodies to be honest yeah i'm going to
wear this around town to impress people
you look if you don't mind me saying
sexy i found myself sitting in a very
sexy way accidentally
well now you know me i'm a hell of a one
for a new year's resolution but i can't
convince you to do a new year's
resolution i don't like new year's
resolutions too much pressure well i do
i just feel like yeah are we giving
ourselves too much pressure are we are
we setting ourselves up for failure yeah
i think we are really because i people
always say to me oh you're a hell of a
one for making new year's resolutions i
am but i'm also pretty casual at
like not doing them as well
i like i like how you like yourself as
you're breaking the rules that's part of
my resolution this year i've got two
resolutions this year
are you going to say it now i think i
should right all right hold on wait a
minute right
wait
what cool it's double barreled this one
first one stop wrestling tigers well
that's a good one i think this is a good
idea second one stop lying
well that's a difficult one it relates
to the first one oh does it yeah
actually my my actual real new year's
resolutions this year are
if in a month you drink
alcohol
right in that month you can't eat fish
if in a month you eat fish
in that month you can't drink alcohol do
you know if you wrote that down
and then put it in like a tin can and
buried it
somebody might find that in three
thousand years and think that was a
religion
and start following dom
the church of uh
no uh no alcohol or fish not in the same
week not on any given month if you can't
is that a month month so if you have a
drink so say you had a lager shandy
no way you're having a cod no no so if
you had say a whiskey and soda february
you're not having a salmon sandwich
until march and then say for instance
you had a pizza
with uh what are those little salty fish
called anchovies one of my favorite
fishes so say you had uh say april 3rd
you will not be having a pint of lager
to me yeah
i know it's quite difficult now when you
look at me directly
like there right there i can't see your
christmas hat all i can see is the white
trim and it looks like a haircut
it looks like you've peroxide blended
you hold on brilliant i'm gonna have a
look at myself though great
i could see you with that hair can you
like a kind of polar bear comb over yes
sorry then on
i'll get some how have i get so much
weight and not as much red as you i
don't know it's probably just the way
the cookie is crumbled yours looks great
like you've had a how about my balls
really close to my mouth yeah why is
that hanging there oh i'm saying this
it's obscuring my vision my ball
hey tom yeah
we're going to have a very special quiz
and quiz yesterday because it's
christmas
and we like to see who the listeners of
this show is so the vast two of them
come on and we're going to ask them
questions not
only about law their rings but
the filming of lord of the rings the
trilogy which i would argue is still
about lord of the rings but we're
getting specific we're not going to say
in the books blah blah blah we're going
to see in the films
so this is for people who really know
the films who don't it doesn't matter if
you know the book if you really know the
films you might do well in this trivia
and who have we got
on this week
[Music]
billy you join me here
in the same arena that you were five
seconds ago yes to have a quiz with the
wonderful sabrina and guy hello civilian
guy tell us where you come from the two
of
sabrina first oh thank you um i am from
new york but i currently live in
connecticut i can't hear her though
guy cannot hear sabrina i don't know if
this is a problem but we'll we'll fire
on because that's how we do it at the
friendship you guys will give me hand
signals yes
you can use this as a go-between and and
from connecticut and um uh guy where are
you from where do you hail from
so the joke is that i'm from the shire
i'm in new hampshire
new hampshire nice
now dom yeah if you were to find new
hampshire if my hand was the united
states of america yeah where would you
see new hampshire is this is new york
over here here we have california mexico
down below i have no idea but i'm gonna
take a stab and say right in the middle
of your hand right here yeah
guy is he close
i'm going to have a go uh
here
just on the index finger
so uh do do you guys know where boston
is yes magnitude where i'm an hour
directly north of boston you're going
north of boston dumb right okay that's
where all those little states are aren't
they they're pain and stuff no one
really yeah that's why we you know we
all have to share a football team we all
share the new england patriots oh yeah
just on the bandwagon with those guys
there you go and there's the t-shirt to
prove are they very good never never
forget nice guy do you know what the
national dish of new hampshire is
what would you get
all my canadian relatives would be
asking for poutine or something all
right chips
is just like a meat pie
meat pie and what about sabrina what's
the what's the
food that's mainly
great question i've only lived here for
about a year so i don't know
too much about connecticut um new york
is pizza right here that they have great
pizza oh yeah this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
now guys we all understand that
sometimes the festive season can bring
about some emotions that you normally
much better at dealing with at other
times of the year better help is here to
help you out betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counselling
done securely online
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easier and free to change counsellors
if needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available if you need
it
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
and read their testimonials that are
posted daily visit betterhelp.com
onion that's better h-e-l-p and join the
over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional in
fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counsellors in all 50 states
special offer for the friendship onion
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
hey guys are you looking to fill a space
in your company with that special one in
a million employees someone who you
think is very difficult to find how are
you going to find them you don't need
luck no no you need indeed indeed is a
hiring partner that gets you what you
really want a short list of quality
candidates as fast as possible because
you can do it all you can attract
interview and hire all at indeed indeed
partners with you on every step of the
hiring process so you can find talent
with the skills you need through tools
like indeed instant match assessments
and virtual interviews
indeed makes it easier for star
applicants to shine with over
135 assessment tests from cooking to
coding get started right now with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
onion get a 75 credit at indeed.com
onion indeed dot com slash onion offer
valid through december 31st terms and
conditions apply need to hire
you need indeed well shall we fire into
the quiz right guys now this is very
specific we're going to be looking very
deeply into the movie the lord of the
rings there's six questions and if
needed there will be a tiebreaker and i
will begin by starting with sabrina
asking this question for question one to
sabrina sabrina what were the four
hobbits hiding
wait oh no i'm gonna start again
where
were the four hobbits hiding from the
black rider on the wooded road filmed
that's not the greatest way to
basically what we're trying to say
where
where in new zealand see it's very
specific to the movie here
where in new zealand was the wooded road
filmed
when the four hobbits were hiding under
the tree and the black rider came
very good thank you
okay where in new zealand
if you give us the town the city that
will take that as an answer yes
all right so this is no multiple choice
right there is no no multiple we're
making this one
a christmas difficulty you're allowed
one clue
and and all your questions
i mean i don't know if i want to use the
clue that early exactly i only know one
town
you only know one tune
what is it
wellington
is the correct chat
what an amazing start wow sabrina it's
specifically mount victoria where billy
used to live at yeah we actually filmed
that right behind my house so it was
fantastic sometimes
we went quite far away sometimes but
that time was great i just had my
breakfast and we went under that tree
lovely okay shoot home for lunch come
back uh yeah lovely i love those kind of
days
one nil to sabrina billy it's over to
you and only because she knew one town
in new zealand incredible sometimes
here we go are you ready kind
be kind
one of the actors
got hit in the mouth
while battling the orcs and had his
tooth
knocked
clean out well actually in half
which actor
got his tooth broken into
uh
let's see
viggo had the broken toe
so
he
he's my he's my suspect only because
he's uh
playing so hardcore
uh i'll i'll go with viggo
correct dancer
well done guy fantastic i didn't think
he was going to get that i thought that
was quite easy
i i almost went with sean bean yeah that
would have been another good another
good day
he had uh stabbed in a bar fight or
something and then like asked for an uh
a kit from the bartender and stitched up
his own arm or something and stayed in
he's a crazy guy
do not call him mr bean though he will
punch your jaw loose
[Laughter]
sabrina
it's the second question for you
and the question goes like this wetter
digital invented software for making the
huge armies of middle earth what did
they call this
software which is still i think being
used to this day is used to this day in
many movies up and down hollywood and
california yes
okay okay
i'm gonna go again with the first thing
that comes to my mind and i'm gonna get
cgi
no
cgi but it does have a specific name oh
guys
guys you want to try and steal it for no
point you won't get anything for
stealing
uh
yeah you just heard it the other day i
was uh when i was out doing some yard
work i was listening to the podcast or
you interview with the the gentleman who
founded it richard
taylor what a what a fabulous interview
that was oh
i
i i i want to keep saying meta but i i
don't remember what it was a very close
guy and the answer is massive
the computer program was called it's
called massive and it's amazing
basically they took so that every little
character had its own sort of ai it's so
it would move in a different way and do
different things incredible
apparently when they first switched it
on
about 80 of them turned around and ran
away really yeah they had to reprogram
howard
so it's it's still one one i was going
to cuff that still 1-1
bless you uh
now this is a difficult one i'm afraid
guy
you either know this or you don't that's
right because his first one was easy
that's true come on
billy and dom that said i'm here sitting
on my right
we got qualified in a skill
when we had days off on water rings
it's a skill that you need this
qualification to be allowed to do it
what was the skill
that we got qualified for
good
um let's see i saw i just have to happen
to look at your wikipedia pages
i know you both like surfing uh
billy i know you like fencing yes that's
true
um but you
both took some martial arts so
i i don't remember which martial arts
but it was a martial arts
is that your final answer guy
yes
i'm afraid that's not the correct answer
guy
sabrina you can steal it for no points
if you know it if you steal it you don't
get any points but you do get a t-shirt
yeah
i was gonna say like fencing basically
sword fighting or fencing yeah billy was
already highly qualified in fencing i
was
we got qualified
in scuba diving
we learned how to scuba dive and it was
fantastic it wasn't talking it was
incredible we almost got washed down to
uh antarctica at one point yeah we got
lost in the sea the the cooked streets i
think they call it and if you get lost
in there there's a current that will
take you right down the antarctica but
when he says current it doesn't mean a
raisin it means an aquatic an ocean
curry
now what's the score what's the score
it's one one still one one with two
goals it's hotly poised sabrina one
question each player you still have a
clue if you want it but here we go
sabrina question five
what was
one other movie that matches lord of the
rings grueling
274-day filming schedule what other film
had a filming schedule as long as lord
of the rings or as we like to call it
lottery
let's have a clue on this one oh well
it's your last question so it's a good
time to take a clue sabrina i'll give
you a clue now
if you this again you either know it or
you don't but it is my favorite film
it's my all-time favorite film
it's all right
um
i'm just gonna go for it oh no wait wait
wait
right go on go on
okay
i'm interested i'm at the edge of my
seat here john yeah you should see what
sabrina thinks i'm trying to think of a
long movie
a long hard movie
i'll give you another minor clue based
on a classical piece of literature
i'm sorry based on a classical piece of
literature
[Music]
favorite
film
all time
i hope guy's not looking at um dom's
wood media right now yes sabrina
i'm going to need to get my sleeves
gonna need an answer
notice how the hands never leave the
arms for this one i don't think this is
a book
extra-large
oh my gosh i'm just going to say i know
it's wrong and i know this isn't it but
i can't think of anything else
has sabrina tried probably not
the brain is just about to try guy and
sabrina thinks it is
star wars i don't think so
unfortunately
unfortunately that is not the correct
answer
sabrina thought that was star wars guy
oh do you want to steal it for free well
you said classic literature classic
literature that uh ruled out the star
wars yeah was it you dumb who was in uh
um
one of the star wars movies was in a
recent star wars film yes and you were
wonderful oh thank you bills now do you
want to try and steal it for free guy
for a t-shirt
um i'll say my favorite movie because
like i can only imagine it being a
grueling 274 days and that'd be
gladiator
oh no
yes it's not the right answer guy john
the correct answer is apocalypse now
the francis
coppola clown based on the uh actually i
saw that in the theaters and i remember
taking a date to it oh wow heavy heavy
films it was really awkward the movie
opens up with like martin sheen's butt
in the screen so
i uh i took a date to see the passion of
the christ
um didn't see her again no no
that's for another day it's for another
day it's still one one this to win it
guys guys this is to win it i should
have asked for
i i should have i still have my
for this question this for all the
marbles and just to be clear there is
not a bag of marbles that you can win at
the end of this
that's too bad i lost a mine a long time
ago nice bills
what did new zealand's capital
wellington
change its name to
for the fellowship of the ring's
premiere
wellington changed its name
for the premier is this for me or
sabrina this is for you
and you could win it here we can win it
or we go to a tie
change their name what are they what
would they change your name to rivendell
is that the final answer guys
look at
billy's face
incredible poker player you will see
nothing in my face
um
yeah i'll go with rivendell rivendell
it's not the correct answer i'm afraid
guy what is the correct answer bill
sabrina will tell us oh
all right just have a guess think think
with your mind sabrina use your mind
your brain you don't get this is on the
first t-shirt this isn't to want it
we've got a tie breaker to win it
use the channel like the rivers the
streams inside your brain to create a
thought and then have it come out of
your mouth with your larynx
the shire
closer
guy sabrina said the shire
in fact wellington changed its name for
the
premiere 2
middle east
welcome to middle earth it said in the
airport and and it really was a welcome
to madeleine
the pictures of the airport are amazing
incredible it's so beautiful it's one
one you guys so we're going to go to a
tiebreaker
how does this is if
if it ends in a tie do we both get a
t-shirt if it ends in a tie you both get
a hoodie and a t-shirt oh wow that's
coming out of our pocket
okay we should have confirmed about that
yeah we should have actually how is this
going to work because guy can't hear
sabrina
i say
do
we take one answer each
okay right yeah and then same if it's
the same answer they both won a t-shirt
and a hoodie
great efforts are correct one well of
course
okay here's the question here's your
question
uh literally ladies and gentlemen
that's tie-breaking hush please
in the audience please
which role
did orlando bloom
originally audition
for
that's a fantastic sabrina said the word
crap she said i don't think was her
answer i don't i don't remember a
character i said it under a breath one
of the orcs in maurya was called crap
his name i don't think he auditioned for
that
was it smeagle no just kidding um
guys having to think sabrina's having
green thinking guys
i know it's not um
i'm i'm gonna
guess
frodo okay guys
hold that guess frodo guy has tried i
know it's not aragorn because i've just
read that today that it was sabrina if
you say the same thing and we're both
right or wrong we don't win if you're
wrong guys
if you're a wrong guy you get nothing
what yeah
that's a lesson in life there okay
diddly squat i was trying to ki bits
yeah i guess i think i'm gonna have to
say the
um
use your mind sabrina use your brain use
your brain waves we have one answer from
god i know it's not aragorn that i know
i was gonna say grandma worm tongue just
to annoy your friend
i'm gonna say as well you're gonna say
frodo we have two
answers which are the same yeah they're
both the same and
they're both
wrong i'm afraid ladies and gentlemen it
was not frodo baggins no one was allowed
to play a hobbit who was over five foot
eight
and orlando is six foot nine
whopper i don't know
[Laughter]
the correct answer was faramir
the audition to play faramir
get out you're terrible get out he came
back a week later and they said hang on
a second with a long white wig and they
said we know who you could play
well guys
you've come with nothing and you've left
with nothing and i think that's a lesson
in life it is
you can take that with you down your
long road we don't we don't get to ask
you any questions sure ask a world you
got one question each
see uh
uh does it have to be lord of the rings
no you can ask anything you want guys
all right uh
tolkien's uh best friend in oxford was
uh c.s lewis correct
what does the c stand for
oh it's a question like that
i thought it was going to be tom what's
your favorite movie which we could all
answer now ladies and gentlemen it's
apocalypse now apocalypse now
c the c in c.s lewis is it charles
charles is a good guess actually thank
you should we say charles go for it
charles
is it chad
not the correct answer ah what is it it
was clive
and what's the ad
uh
i forget i just remembered him saying in
that he just had a movie that came out
this fall uh the most reluctant convert
and it's a great movie and he says my my
mother named me clive which i'll always
regret
[Laughter]
brilliant now sabrina do you want to ask
a question since uh guided
it can be about
no you can ask any question but you
don't even have to ask a question you're
probably quite angry with us because
we're not giving you a t-shirt yeah
i would be this has been nothing but
sort of amazing so absolutely not um no
chats
all right since we're in christmas gear
here yeah um
what is your favorite holiday do you
have a favorite holiday
can you repeat our question for me yeah
what is your favorite holiday
ah that's a good question that actually
i would say
i think mine is probably christmas
i like christmas i like i like when
everything closes down and i say that's
it i'm on the sofa
i've got a nice mulled wine i'm watching
old movies and i'm i'm here till january
the 4th i like that yeah that's lovely
i like new year's eve i like new year's
resolutions i like new starts i like
wiping the slate clean of the failure of
last year
i'm beginning again with a new new
opportunity so i would say new year's
eve what about you sabrina what's your
favorite holiday
neither of those actually my um my
favorite uh
i feel like it's not many people's
favorite um is halloween oh no a lot of
people in america love halloween the
scariest of us yeah we do
guys what's your favorite holiday
oh i'd have to agree with christmas
because all the the families together
yeah my uh my kids come home and uh one
of our traditions is uh you know when
you after you've unwrapped your present
and you've looked at it and you've
thanked whoever gave it to you set it
down
you quietly bunch up the paw the paper
into a little ball and we
start randomly throwing all the paper
balls around and we find them for weeks
sometimes months i love that scattered
behind
behind the chairs and
little paper balls from the wrapping
paper whipped around the room well billy
and i both love balls as well and on
that on that note it was fantastic
chatting to you both
have a wonderful wonderful
christmas and new year and thank you
merry christmas and happy new year you
both
well it is the season in california
where the nights are getting longer and
darker and it's getting a little bit
chilly at night and one of the coziest
things that you can do and you and i
have done it but yeah with your family
and your wonderful little dog walking
around is have a little solo stove
experience i love the soul you love
yours i do i love it i go out there and
i load it up with nice wood and i get a
nice fire going because i think a fire
outside it just gives it a focus doesn't
it gives it even enough focus
and i tell you what else i love about it
it's got a smokeless design so i don't
even know how it does it but there's
less smoke yeah it's it's a technology
that is it's not for us to try and
understand you know but the next time
i'm at your house i'd like us to toast
marshmallows on it that's something that
i really want to do i've done that it's
great
and they're super easy to clean as well
i love that about it yeah because i
don't like spend a lot of time cleaning
and i know you like gadgets and i know
you like kind of futuristic looking
stuff and it does look like a little
mini spaceship it's very very cool
upgrade your backyard with a solo stove
fire pit enjoy the mesmerizing flames
and all the opportunities to create some
good moments and lasting memories make
the time with your friends and family
richer with a wonderful solo stove fire
pit and the other great thing is dom
it's really portable so you can move it
around it's not as if you pour it
somewhere and you're stacked
it's easily portable take it to the
beach if you want let the gifting begin
shop solo stoves holiday sale for a huge
site-wide savings now through the end of
the year get 10
off with promo code onion plus a
lifetime warranty and free 30-day
returns get an extra 10
off holiday deals at solostove.com
promo code onion
pendulum therapeutics is the first and
only biotech company to isolate an
important beneficial bacterial strain
and to put that strain into a convenient
new probiotic rich capsule that is
formulated to help manage
type 2 diabetes and nurture your body's
microbiome
now you and i both know that sometimes
when you're feeling a little under the
weather or maybe you've picked up a head
cold or maybe you've been eating some
slightly dodgy food a lot of that is due
to an imbalance in your gut gut health
is very important and at the cutting
edge of medicine nowadays talking about
gut health and the health of your
stomach and your intestine and all that
kind of stuff so
pendulum
is a great thing to give yourself a very
healthy gut and pendulum glucose control
is designed to lower a1c and after meal
blood glucose levels to help you manage
your type 2 diabetes with pendulum you
can feel in control of all your levels
not the other way around if you or
someone you love has type 2 diabetes
take control of glucose levels with
pendulum glucose control
use the code onion at
pendulumlife.com to get 20
off all the products that's p e n d u l
u m l i f e dot com promo code onion for
20 off
[Music]
hi steph
hey billy hey where in the world do you
find yourself steph
i am just west of portland oregon
good coffee place good coffee place very
good
place do you like to be called steph
i do prefer steph thanks for asking oh
no it's all right because you've there's
a little step on your screen there so we
just wanted to make sure
so tom why did we want to meet and speak
to steph well steph since we've began
the podcast has been fashioning up
little drawings of the two of us
and our activities during last week's
podcast but doing it very quickly right
steph like within a few hours
i do try yeah amazing and why do you go
by the name kilk and tuna on instagram
what's that about it's a reference to a
very silly family story
we're
i was with my dad and older brothers up
in northern ontario on a fishing trip
and when the float plane was coming back
to pick us up it was very very late like
hours
too late
and we had already gotten rid of most of
our food we burned the food that was
burnable because we didn't want to pack
out so much stuff
and we were facing the possibility of
spending an extra night in this cabin
without any food the only food we had
left
was an eight ounce can of starches tuna
and another small tin of click which we
think is like generic canadian spam
but we only bought it because we thought
the name was funny
right and so when i was joining twitter
i was trying i'm not very good at being
creative on the spot and i'm trying to
think of
a username that hadn't been taken you
know something relevant and i just i
couldn't think of anything nothing was
working nothing wasn't taken so i
finally just said fine cooking tuna and
it was free and i'm like
it's not going to matter no one's ever
going to hear this or know about this
who's going to care nice so is that
is that now your name that you do art
under is that how people can find your
art
yes i'm on both twitter and instagram
and click and tuna click and tune and we
would suggest everyone go and look at it
because it's amazing stuff isn't it it
makes us laugh every week it's very
funny we love it it's brilliant yeah
it's very funny and you've also done i
appreciate that you've done like a
coloring book is that right steph can
you tell us about it's only three pages
let's not call it a book
over two pages is a book just the same
as anything over three people can be a
riot right yeah so there you go that's
something you've learned today tom or a
few a few right through yeah yeah so
tell us about your coloring book of
three pages
no i mean i just wanted to do something
special for the fans for christmas
because a lot of people have been
enjoying the illustrations and i figured
christmas is coming i want to do
something a little special and i've had
some experience drawing coloring pages
so i thought
why not
so i have done one
eat the world themed coloring page yes
that's you you do it sitting at a table
enjoying various things that you've
eaten during that segment
and i did a christmas themed page which
is dom as the ghost of christmas present
and billy as ebenezer scrooge
and the third page is mary and pippen
themed it's it's very cute it's little
mary and pippen oh lovely ah we actually
oh yeah we have your coloring book here
and i actually saw it this morning and i
love it three pages well i'm calling it
uh a coloring book steph because that's
what it is and how would people do that
how would people find this three pages
coloring book
well i have uploaded them to dropbox
from which anyone who has the link
can download them and print them and
color them however they like well please
if anyone would like to download that
and i i would recommend you do
color them in and send them ears yeah
take a picture and send it to the
friendship onion at
castmedia.com with a cabbage okay yeah
the one of billy uh of mary and pippen
his little kids is very cute
yeah thank you great it's it's such a
lovely work we'd love to see some of
these colored then yeah that would be
i'd love to see them too right yeah so
if people could do that
over the christmas period when there's
nothing on tv
just get out your colour and pencils and
get these done for us now thank you and
steph what was it in particular that
because obviously you're you you listen
to the podcast what what was it in
particular that that kind of made you
subscribe and tune in and continue to
listen and then get so inspired to draw
stuff are you always drawing stuff is
that just kind of what what you do in
your day
it's just kind of a thing that i do yeah
one of my favorite hobbies i draw i
cross stitch you know things like that
but when i listen to the first episode
of the friendship i mean i've been
looking forward to it for a while and
the episode was lovely
and the story
of you don giving billy that card i'll
watch your back if you'll watch mine
it's just
the sweetest goddamn thing i've ever
heard
and he didn't keep the card and he has
no memory of giving me the cast yeah
that's terrible because it's the best
story i know
you should start pretending you can
remember yeah
someone else art art of any kind is a
good way to
vent big feelings so i loved the episode
loved that
story what we've got i sat down and
scribbled something and i uploaded it
and billy liked it and retweeted it and
i'm like holy [__]
so then it just sort of became a thing
that i did and i yeah there's the cross
stitch yeah cross stitch i've been
trying to learn how to cross stitch for
a while because i like doing
relatively contained kind of repetitive
motions like sewing and i tried you
should it's good it's a lovely hobby you
can do really cool things with it oh did
you do that did you do that horse or as
i did this is cross stitched it's a
horse it's um
one of the banners hanging behind
theoden and eteress wow i designed it
myself and stitched it onto a jacket do
you have a favorite of the three films
um steph and do you have a favorite
scene in the trilogy
hopefully my favorite scene
actually features billy it's the scene
where faramir
is writing to us gilead on his suicide
ride
and um pippin singing is superimposed
over that i love it yeah i love i love
what pete did to that scene there i mean
the cross edit yeah that's a good thing
i was i was lucky enough when i was
doing the song the last goodbye that i
got to
sit in in pete's edit room and watch his
mind as he kind of works those things
out
where
he was doing the hobbit obviously the
battle of the five armies at that time
and how he would take footage and go
you know he'd make a scene and then he
go now and he'd start again and by the
end it'd be a totally different scene
with the same footage and how he can
mold that together is just
just incredible that's what i think one
of you guys i trust his genius yeah yeah
just the
you know the
imagination he'd just see these things
and put it all together you know kind of
like what you're doing with your art
yeah thanks for that very generous we
always look forward to seeing what what
has sparked your interest uh this week
that you know you've you've drawn it's
really fun and the fact that you're
including like john here and there and
um johnny cloaks i love including john
he's been a very good sport about my
inclusion of him because i have drawn
him in less than flattering situations i
think he's
well i hope maybe you
in this christmas episode when you do
your drawing perhaps you will uh will
will make a
um an appearance in your own art
could die
but maybe
that would be fun and what you doing for
christmas of you have you um have you
bought all your christmas gifts are you
making any plans for christmas
oh yeah i have three small children so
christmas is very fun around here
what what ages
how old they are nine and six and five
and they love you guys oh that's cool so
do you watch lord my six-year-old
daughter my six-year-old daughter will
intentionally cause mischief in the
house and blame it on mary and pippin
brilliant
that's fantastic
well i hope you guys have a have a great
christmas and new year
we really do and please
if you've got the time keep doing the
art because we love it yeah we do if i
don't if there is ever a time when i
don't upload an illustration one of your
episodes you can assume
i'm either dead or in like mortal peril
oh god
thank you
steph take care of yourself happy
holidays and all that kind of thing
and please everybody get the coloring
book it's three pages and get it colored
then over christmas yeah cheers we'd
love to see it we'll put a link to the
dropbox in the show notes so you guys
can uh oh that's a great idea yeah
thanks a lot steph lovely to meet you
and hopefully we'll see you around the
friendship onion a lot have a wonderful
christmas guys
happy new year william it's time for
questions
and
other humans that have sent them in to
us here we should have a jingle for that
because we do emails and emails but we
don't do a question sir jingle do we can
you think of one just now
what rhymes with questions uh
pedestrians
pedestrians and questions
particular sessions no not really but
we'll work on that right
this question comes from bobby
in trenton
nashua new hampshire but they all talk
like this
bobby says hey billion dollars wonder
what some of your favorite christmas
movies are i saw on instagram and
thomas's christmas camel mom which
person do you like the best
happy holidays guys it's a great show
hey
i love this i like the way you're
talking oh you sound like you're from
new hampshire yeah i'm from new
hampshire i was uh born and brought up
there you know yeah in nashua new
hampshire you know it of course i know
it yeah i appreciate it i'm the man i'm
the man you're a man i'm the [__] man
you're a piece of [__] all right
favorite christmas movie yes i love a
christmas carol and i like all versions
of a christmas carol black and white
versions animated versions uh muppet
versions of course colored versions
black and white yeah i like black and
white what right i'm just asking i said
black and white uh i think my favorite
version might be the alistair sim
black and white version but i also like
a christmas carol book oh you really
like the black and white it's your
favorite yeah i really like it listen to
that's dumb
michael caine's in a christmas a muppet
christmas carol and i like that
he is he is michael caine's in it and i
like that how's your michael king
i don't think i can do him right carry
on
um and uh
i like the jim carrey uh christmas carol
as well
so i like all the christmas carols
outside of that a christmas story do you
know a christmas story american classic
comedy no it was on the plane
a christmas story a christmas story it's
the story of a young i would say eight
to nine year old boy who wants a very
specific cowboy gun for christmas and
does he get one he'll have to tune in
what about you
um i like christmas vacation
yeah but we're talking about christmas
movies is that not one oh all right i
thought you meant oh yeah
for christmas no i like the movie we
shave your cheeks
yeah holiday holiday holiday rock that's
not the chin
no it's not as if it's similar to that
yes but i like that
i like a laugh yeah of course you like
it and so where they stab the turkey and
it explodes and then all the christmas
lights fall off yeah and they get a tree
and it's too big and a squirrels and it
jumps on somebody the grana thing
and he wants all the lights on it's
brilliant brilliant
well bobby thanks for that question have
you got a question barbie yeah are you
ready john yeah which one are you going
to pick hold on i'm going to skip across
here
i haven't i haven't re i haven't read
this yet right tom yeah
frederick from doncaster um
says i was wondering what your ideal
place would be to spend the holidays
i've never been but mine is a cozy cabin
in the rocky mountains
oh that's a good idea he's asking where
would we find the rocky mountains if my
hand
was the united states of america
where would you find the rocky mountains
dom that said new york over there this
is california down here you've got
mexico up here canada would it be kind
of like the close to the tip of your
thumb
up here rocky mountains yes
yeah johnny clue says yes
and does the rocky mountains go all the
way down through canada and all the way
down through america and all the way
down through south america it snakes
into aspen right because uh
uh jim carrey and jeff daniels have that
amazing moment where he says
we thought the rocky mountains would be
rockier than this
john denver's full of stairs
so
frederick has never been to the rocky
mountains but he'd love that with a warm
fire he says lots of windows as the snow
falls and there's trees all around
lovely what a lovely i think he's drawn
a lovely picture there has frederick
from doncaster
i've had some fantastic kind of snowden
christmases austria switzerland you and
i went snowboarding to france one
christmas that was fantastic it was you
and i have had christmas in
pen what penrith and the latest are you
laughing about me on the on the chair
left no i'm not i'm laughing at my
sister margaret who came on that holiday
you remember
and you remember we all went skiing and
snowboarding and she didn't go on a
friend she didn't want to do it no no
but she said she could see us skiing
and i said really because we were quite
far away she said yeah i saw you going
round and round the mountain
i was like i don't think we went round
and round we went straight like down
kind of zigzag
and she says no i could see you going
round and round i don't know what she
was watching yeah she had a few she
played
yeah um we've spent time in penrith
together we've spent time in hawaii
together for christmas we spent a lot of
christmases together yeah maybe too many
yeah
you should pull back um
but in terms of an ideal place that i've
not been to yet
i wouldn't mind right christmas right
going down in antarctica
just yourself
just me and a leopard seal
and a couple of penguins yeah lovely
penguins are funny do you know why polar
bears don't eat penguins yep
they don't live in the same place they
don't live in the same place and for all
of our uh british listeners out there
yeah the polar bears can't get the
wrappers off
good point that's a great job hey what
about you i i would i'd do the same as
frederick doncaster i think you'd go to
doncaster no i think i i do like the
whole
log fire big windows snow outside that's
that's christmas to me
even though we probably wouldn't have
that this year because i'm staying here
but
yeah christmas for me is snow
and fires and mild wine and yeah if you
had to let's say you're snowed in right
with your family
it's freezing
you're locked not only in the house yeah
but the other rooms yeah of the house
uh-huh
there's created a seal of ice around
them you can't get into your bedroom you
can't get into your bathroom you can't
get into your kitchen it's freezing
your family look at you they say oh
billy we're freezing cold
light the fire light the fire and you
say we've not got any fuel we've got
nothing we've not right any paper i
can't get any wood right
nothing we've got a lighter
if to save your family's life yeah yeah
you're gonna get in the fireplace and
set it on fire
would you do it
i would do that in a in a new york
secondary would you i would burn my
tears to save not only my family but
anyone's family imagine the stench oh
you could well the chimney's going to
deal with most of that yeah but some of
you'll get a backdraft like that robert
de niro film yeah and it will be the
smell of
burning feces but it'd be a good movie i
think it'd be up there with uh the
martian
because he used his didn't he to uh
plant potatoes
that's right matt damien but this time
matt damien would be setting fire to
save his family angelina jolie and i
don't know who's playing the kids but
fantastic movie i'd go and see that
what would we call it christmas log
[Laughter]
moving on that's my favorite christmas
movie now
oh that matt damien's brewing isn't that
he is brilliant matt damien um well that
was great i think we're done with the
questions
you join us here in the billion dom
office when i say us i mean myself
dominic and my good friend william boyd
hello
to
enjoy a wonderful
christmas
juicy
liquid tradition what is it bills would
you say that this juicy liquid is a
tradition the world dom i think it's
probably much more traditional in the
united states although i have heard of
people having this in britain so we'll
find out more about this juicy liquid
later on but right now we'd like to
introduce you all to eggnog a nog made
of egg
cheers dom are we trying it are we well
are we don't we oh okay i thought we
normally kind of but before we try who
made this dumb johnny close made the
eggnog this was freshly made this
morning with cage-free eggs
and a little bit of cream some
organic nog some sugar
and sometimes you can add some alcohol
alcohol sounds like that i'll take
you've had too much but this one is
known as this and eggnog let's have a
give it a little go see cheers says
right
lumpy
where's the lumps
what's the lump stock i don't think we
should ask that was a surprise something
we should ask johnny about the luminance
that was a real surprise in my mouth i
think he probably need to whisk it a
little bit more is it supposed to be
lumpy
i mean would you say that's just a glass
of custard i hold on till i just have a
look at it tastes just like a glass of
custard to me i can't see anything about
lumps no lumps is it supposed to be like
it's definitely not supposed to be lumpy
you definitely definitely hold on to it
look through johnny clue's here
is it supposed to be lumpy i'll i'll
read you a little bit of a blurb here
bills while you figure out if it should
be lumpy or not it's lumpy yeah
supposed to be lumpy johnny please come
use a mic
um yeah
should it be lumpy john uh no but
why is it lumpy
i mean it's what bumps
is separated
those are the nugs eggs
separated yeah sorry i didn't bring my
uh whisker is that what i usually bring
yeah yeah so just use that for work it's
not unpleasant but it's probably not
supposed to it's
it was a real surprise when i drunk that
yeah try and make it more liquid john it
was very nice of you to make this for us
though
don't worry johnny johnny i'll i'll read
this it is believed that eggnog began in
europe as early as the 13th century the
13th century in 1201
they were drinking this wow
oh can i have some eggnog that's how
they all talked in the twelve medieval
monks it said in britain we're known to
posit don't know what that means really
a warm ale punch with eggs and figs
over time this likely merged with the
various milks and wines on offer into
what is commonly known nowadays in
social gatherings ag as eggnog is it the
lumps putting you off i can't eat it i
can't drink it with a lump stomp
can we put it can we save it through
something do you have some scree or
something think but i can't every time i
take it i get lumps it's like it's when
it's sour
but you know what i mean but think
custard is that not just a glass of
custard well i can't go over the lumps
holding custard
i'm going to put it through my teeth it
won't go through my teeth cause i'm so
lumpy
i'll read you something else by the 17th
century sherry
became the primary ingredient in eggnog
and it was popular to use this eggy
beverage on toast oh no as a toast
to one's health and prosperity the
society primarily consumed it because
milk eggs and sherry were scarce
commodities in europe at the time and
this was seen to be a kind of exclusive
drink i like it i absolutely love the
flavor yeah but the lumps are fairly
awful if we could get rid of the lumps
somehow how would we do it because i get
really drunk on this with you add in
something like pork
what would you put in something like a
sweet wine maybe even a dessert wine a
gewurztramina this is already quite
sweet though it's sweet wouldn't you do
something like a brandy or something
brandy would be good or a vodka wait
would you hear this george washington
devised his own recipe
that at that time only the most
courageous guests would partake in it
tom it was attributed that the recipe of
this first president was a boozy batch
of brandy
rye whiskey
jamaican rum
and sherry god i get it i mean that's oh
he's strange
hang on johnny clues is strained what
did you put it through just put it
through a napkin that's a toilet paper
went through his t-shirt
it doesn't seem as it doesn't seem as
it's not as cold but that's true cheers
cheers we'll try it in its liquid form
as it should be presented i'd like to
know what it was put through
a little bit was it jump
still lumpy but less very slumpy
it's no ah i love the flavor i love it i
mean i really love the flavor but i mean
as you can see dom look at the lumps on
the side there
what
what is that if i knew where the lumps
was i could get myself down what is the
lumps
john's john's saying something but not
unsure mike hold on
coagulation
but i'll go on here as a rich and often
alcoholic drink eggnog became a familiar
fixture during the holiday season across
the colonies of the united states
eventually the new country of the united
states adopted it in the 1700s eggnog
was frequently made without alcohol
which is how we're drinking it today and
each region or state i would guess would
adapt the drink to their own personal uh
taste for example in the south people
tended to prefer whiskey over rum so
that's where you would go oh yeah rum
would be nice in there rum would be good
wouldn't it kind of richer hearty but i
like where you're going with brandy
yeah
sweet whiskey
not a great not a good wit not one that
you spend a lot of money on but just
like a blended whiskey i like it and if
you got drunk in it i think you'd feel
very ill in the morning because there's
a lot of sugar in that isn't it doesn't
that help you if you're getting drunk
no is that the other way
well i tell you what the flavor is
fantastic john i'd like to thank you for
that it's what it's a really lovely
drink like i would have that at the end
of a meal as instead of a sweet yeah
exactly you could have that as a kind of
pudding i like it too
you see it in the supermarkets of the
united states at christmas time in the
milk section cream section and i always
kind of think that it looks
revolting
i don't think my mum would like it
because it contains raw eggs doesn't it
did could she not take this you're
pregnant she's just not a final role
right all right not a fan
what
will be that john's got something here
it's it's the cream that is separate i
didn't think it had anything to do with
this well the good thing is it's nothing
to do with john because it's during the
pasteurization process and
john was not he was he wasn't even
present when this was pasteurized
so he's only involved in the flavor and
the flavor i can tell you is incredible
there's a treat we'll talk about some of
the variations that we've got here so go
on dom in the early days eggnog was
served warm by professor uh
jerry thomas who printed the first
bartending guide in the 1800s eggnog was
enjoyed cold at that point and then it
says here in 1887 printing of the
bartender's guide noted the
hot eggnog was very popular in
california while the others were served
over rice or cooled rice ice
or cooled in a tub of ice the recipes
use brandy
rum
madeira wine
sherry or hard cider lovely and then you
you tell us what countries around the
world do with eggnog dumb this isn't
going to be easy in poland the jewish
communities have long enjoyed kogel
mogul
and in germany could you help me here
i'll try
i'll go i'll
is popular homemade ed liqueur
in puerto rico
coconut juice or milk was added today
the eggs are typically left out and the
drink is called coquito coquito mass
and in mexico eggnog became
rom pope
with mexican cinnamon vanilla and either
rum or grain alcohol i probably wouldn't
have liked that one do you know why dom
you're not a fan of cinnamon i don't
like cinnamon although you like you like
it a little bit more than you used to
yeah when i was younger i went to a
place that had
um
big dippers
you know roller coaster roller coasters
big dippers and before i went
a friend had made me some cinnamon toast
and after going on the roller coasters i
was as sick as a dog
and i think i related the cinnamon to
being sick yeah so for years i couldn't
eat it
i don't mind cinnamon but i don't
absolutely love it
um
i like this i like eggnog
so dom the basic formula the basic
formula for eggnog has not changed over
the years eggs are beaten with sugar
milk cream and quite often a distilled
spirit or fortified wine lovely it's
still a favorite for holiday parties
there are several modern renditions of
the classic eggnog recipe and
and they can be quite fun
and unique
i love it i like it too i feel as if
it's got alcohol in it i think john
might have put a little spices this has
been served quite cold and i would say
moving forward if i were to ever have
eggnog again i would like it as cold as
possible almost sat in a chilled ice
bucket and then directly drank because
when it's cold it's good i wouldn't like
this at room temperature
i would like it without the lumps the
next time i have it i'd like without
lumps should we give it some skills go
on time
flavor
and or taste
well flavor or taste john has absolutely
outdone himself i i don't really drink
eggnog and i i'm sure i have done a
couple of times over my life i don't
know if i have
so i don't really know how it compares
to other eggnogs but i would say the
flavor i would give it a 8.7 i love the
flavor i love the flavor too as nogs go
i think the egg version is probably the
best version of a nog i'll give it
i'll give it an 8.3 i mean that's high
for flavor and if you think if you took
out the actual revoltingness of the
lumps that could have been up there in
the names yeah it could have right
yes there is
going to lose points how does it look
john how does it look to you
i mean as far as nogs go well the color
the hue yeah very much enjoy it's almost
a kind of
dull primrose yellow you know it's a
pleasant yellow
i like it like a kind of
dusky yellow would you have your walls
done like this would you possibly yeah
possibly maybe in a dining room um i
like it um the the only thing like you
said that brings it down when you when
you give the glass a little bit of a
swirl is that the lumps cling to the
side as if trying to escape the glass
there is uh
there is a through line here of the
lumps really influencing everything
about this drink gonna bring down the
score for me it's got the score's been
pumped up with the aesthetics due to the
color but brought way down with the
lumps and i'm gonna give the aesthetic
a two point six that's loadon that is
low
because i i agree with you i think it's
a lovely color if i had to see what
color it was i would say it was an
eggnog yeah is it oh yeah i would think
that's a good idea and
it's absolutely it's lovely
but
the lumps the lumps yeah they seem to be
a sticking point both in this
conversation and in your throat
i'll give it a 4.7 oh you've been kind
well the lumps yeah the lumps it's an
issue and then finally usefulness i
think it would be very useful in apart
from drinking and enjoying it
what other ways would could you find
eggnog useful well if you ever needed
lumps for anything i don't know why you
would need lumps there's plenty in my
eggnog yeah if you wanted to
paint your bedroom walls with something
that you could lick off later that would
be pretty good yeah and it looked like
an artix because of the lumps exactly uh
good at a christmas party i like the
fact that you can do so many different
variations of it like you said you can
add coconut with milk you can enjoy it
with brandy you can enjoy it with
madeira wine you can do seri sherry you
can do hard cider i like that you can do
it hot you can do it cold it's
relatively versatile would you be a load
say for instance i had um
a sort of sponge cake could i pour that
on it oh i think that would be nice
would that be would people i mean would
it is it dare a gear i think that might
be dedicated i mean even a christmas
pudding from britain that we know well
you could pour a little or non-alcoholic
i was going to say but also possibly
alcoholic eggnog over the top to cool it
down i'd like that i could i would put
that on ice cream mince pie innocent
it's bumped it up actually i think it's
very useful yeah i'm gonna give its
usefulness score
an 8.6
8.6 that's quite good dom i i'm getting
used to the lumps now i just squeeze
them against the top of my mouth with my
tongue yeah i just burst them
out for usefulness i agree i think it'd
be very useful we have around the house
i'm going to give a
9. one wow
so that
was eggnog one of the most christmasy of
juices of all time and if you want to
send in
or sending suggestions for a food or
drink item to the show you can send it
to us at the friendship on your netcast
media.com um
and we'll hopefully enjoy it at a later
date i would love that um and i'd like
to thank johnny johnny clues for making
this lovely eggnog it might not have
supposed to have all those lumps but you
know things can go wrong when you're
cooking especially around the christmas
time you know don't stress about it just
enjoy it enjoy it just enjoy it
[Music]
right john it's that time of the week
when we get to listen something that we
will suggest or or comment on is it
funky or is it not funky is it funky for
you or not is it funky for you let's
have a listen tom who's this coming from
this
my friend is coming from wendy oh wendy
okay
hey billy and um this is wendy from
brunswick georgia
i just recently found out there's
actually a christmas song that's popular
in the new york new jersey area
it's called dominic the donkey
i recommend listening to it i'm not
going to spoil it
it's on youtube if you want to find it
hope you enjoy thanks
dominic the donkey
it's very loud in my ears but as far as
let's have a listen to this if you got
it have you got the song i've heard this
before actually have you
very big in new york and surrounding
areas you can't meet it can it oh that's
maybe
hey
it's dominick the donkey
king
the italian christmas
[Applause]
hey i left a whole bunch of shitty
apples behind me i don't know apple's
just my [__] i love that donkey that
italian ducky i love that song wanna
know where i've been just follow my [__]
all the way backwards through my
homeland in italy and collaborate be
like hansel and [__] glow
that's good that i loved it i like
having uh songs named after me there any
songs uh after your name billy yes uh
john i'll just give you the um
oh my darling billy boyd
oh nice who's actually called billy boy
billy don't be a hero
yeah can only think of billy don't be a
hero and now we've got dominic donkey
but in terms of a
a barometer of funk based on brahms
being no funk and prince at his most
purple and funkadelic how funky was that
song
lily
uh i'm gonna say yep
that
was
a level of funk
i'm going to say shaking steven's funk
shaking as quite a quite funky
like old-fashioned funky all right if
you're going shaking stephen you're all
shaky i'm going to get down that same
sort of road
and i'm going to go
with
sydney devine sydney devine what a
choice
shaking stephen's had a christmas song
didn't he did he do behind green though
that's not a christmas isn't it no i
think he didn't he didn't wasn't shaky
famous for
we'll have a rock and roll christmas
isn't that him
[Music]
anyway
thanks for your funky uh
song suggestions and remember if you
want to send anything in to us guys
whether it's a suggestion for billion
dollar meet the world or a question or a
voicemail you can send it to us at the
friendship onion cast media.com
or you can send us your uh messages on
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion you can leave comments
on our youtube channel and if you want
to subscribe to us and give us a five
star rating and tell us what you think
of the show we would very much
appreciate it because the more nice
comments and nice stars we get the more
we can make this show and we love making
the show and if you want to look as cool
as us with friendship onion uh
merchandise you can get that at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com
yeah if you want these actual socks that
i'm wearing right now you can't have
them because i'm taking them home we
didn't open any gifts can we open one
each let's one open a gift can we do one
each come on you guys have been sending
us right corn bills
i want that long one now what's that one
that what do you know what i think this
will be
is it a record no i think their shoes
i think it might be a giant thing of
smarties oh that'd be brilliant we'll
probably need a knife or scissors you
get for people who are just listening
and not watching doms is the shape of
uh what would you call that a box it's a
coffin for a rabbit
a coffin for a flat rabbit and minds is
long like a tube i would say about two
feet long guys i'm not getting in this
without a knife or a pair of scissors
it's full of sellotape we need some sort
of knife i'm gonna break a nail dom wait
what is this
thanks
john uh is that drawn is that drawn is
it
is it is it if that is drawn have a look
at that ladies and gentlemen that is
drawing on youtube uh people who are not
on youtube who are just listening it is
a painting
i would say an 8 by 25
of me and dom as mary and pippen and it
is absolutely incredible i'm going to
read the letter
please
i don't
is it long
um
let me just have a look
my name is sean springer i live in the
gold coast australia i'm a 28 year old
tattoo artist
and giving out to people is all i've
known how to do
just wanted to see and show you guys i
really appreciate the work that you do
i've sent you guys an email to the
friendship onion in case you don't see
it here it is it basically is saying i'm
a big fan of the podcast
i've been swallowed up by your work uh
by my work and navigating the pandemic
lately but a few weeks ago i came up for
a break a fresh of air a fresh breakfast
and i found the friendship onion this is
definitely going to help me get through
both of these in the future i've already
caught up all the episodes and i'm
listening weekly ah thanks a lot man a
few months ago i drew a picture for
viggo mortensen
um
brilliant bro i don't want to do the
whole thing but
um
thanks but he's doing uh drawings of a
lot of it but that drawing is
unbelievable and he's a tattoo artist
so if you want to get this on your back
dom
i don't know would you like to get this
tattooed on your back maybe i'll
consider it
you need a bigger back
you need to start working a little bit
more but that is absolutely incredible
work now this coincidentally enough was
sent to us by steph who we've just had
on the show the joking
from kill kill and tuna click and [__]
click and tuner and she sent us a whole
introductory
cross cross-stitching
set
where you can do your own
cross stitches you've been wanting to
try that i can't wait over the christmas
period i'm going to take myself on
holiday somewhere and i'll take these
would you call them discs
these crosses and does it tell you how
to do it yeah there's an instruction
thing here i'm gonna cross stitch your
face and bring it back from my holiday
to present to you that is fantastic tom
i'd like to have a go at that as well
but you can show me how to do it once
you've worked it out well thank you
steve don't tell me we've got time for
we'll we'll open these off camera let's
open one more all right come on then
pass me one over dom
oh that's open already what's that
what's this one
oh
hang on it's got a little gold thing on
it i'm stealing that
it doesn't work though
great job
what have you got snow is falling all
around us all around us
and playing
having fun
since the season of love and
understanding
merry christmas
everyone i think that's shaky that's it
was gonna have a party
tonight i'm gonna kiss your balls
underneath the mistletoe oh [__]
midnight light yeah
this is another piece of merchandise
you're joking who's that this isn't a
christmas gift this is something that
the staff have bought for themselves
well you have a look at us one time
because this is bo billy and tom here's
a snack i'm sure you'll love hawkins
cheesies it's a canadian favorite came
about when someone at the company saw a
newly developed machine that extrudes
pellets of cornmeal to feeding cattle
they thought hey if we deep fry them and
cover them with cheese that'll be
delicious
i don't think i have ever seen something
look any more cheesy than that look at
that
that looks orange powdered food i
haven't ever seen
that looks like it would stain every
part of your body that it would touch
and probably uranus on the way out i
know a lot about you dom and i'm pretty
sure that you would get naked to eat
that
i would get naked and have a shower as
soon as i've finished and possibly have
to put my finger up my bum yeah after it
well it would make it etchy it might
make it that looks so cheesy should we
put that on an episode of billion dollar
in the world at some point i don't see
why not it's already sounds like a
fantastic thing thanks person canadian
person who's very salty who's it from um
it's from the delph's family in calgary
and they said they're so salty make sure
you get half paint or
a full paint for mary and pepper
of your favorite ale on hand imagine
that a nice pint of beer lovely a nice
cheesies very salty dog very solid well
the good news is this contains disodium
phosphate and i don't get enough to
sodium phosphate so get a little bit so
that's brilliant good for your knees
thanks for the gift that was uh we'll
open some more presents maybe as the new
year unfolds
keep sending presents we love them well
that was a sparkling christmasy festive
jingle balls episode and william i would
just like to say to you
merry
christmas
dom
i've had a great time this year on the
fellowship are you with you
it's worship on you
[Laughter]
it's been a long day yes i've had a
great time this year on a friendship
onion with you i i love to see that
you're listening to me mm-hmm i love
that always listen and here's to many
many more this time next year we'll have
mountains of more gifts and we'll be
drunk as monkeys
merry christmas everybody happy
christmas yesterday 2022 all the best
see ya
[Music]